archeologists from the University of Tel
Aviv have used radiocarbon dating to
pinpoint the arrival of domestic camels
in the Middle East and they say that
this science directly contradicts the
Bible's version of events camels are
mentioned as pack animals in the
biblical stories of Abraham Joseph and
Jacob Old Testament stories that
historians peg between 2,000 and 1,500
BC but the archaeologists from tel aviv
university say camels weren't
domesticated in israel until centuries
later more like 900 BC been as a member
of the tribe how do you feel about this
this fight between science and religion
no [ __ ] it's nice when science comes
through you know one of the you know
Mormons take an unfair degree of abuse
because they're nonsensical history is
so easily disprovable to people who
don't know ancient history like we know
Jesus didn't come over here on a boat
right you're on a train doors right
that's not Indians aren't red-skinned
because the gods smited them right like
that Indians are the Lost Tribes of
Israel you realize I realize the Mormon
right but they're but they're but the
ones that are dark because they had to
explain those were those were smited
those were the lead the Nephites the
black skinned right so it's mining does
it but the but the story of course the
the what's unfair for the grief that the
Mormons take in that regard is that it's
really no it's not it's just more easily
disproven dumb enough to try and invent
a religion that's not moderate well they
worked out they were I mean he was smart
enough to invent a religion that enabled
him to say you know I just glanced into
a hat and it turns out I can [ __ ]
thirteen your followers right but anyway
it's not that different than what we're
talking about here it's just this is it
takes a little more science to disprove
those stories too and so yeah here we
know what you we know the
stories were written you know when the
source we're not written
contemporaneously or even close and so
they're simply made-up they're not true
really all well they're fables they are
fables but I would say and I you know
personally believe that they're fables
especially the things that are in direct
contradiction to the natural laws of
science but I think that all this really
does prove or provide evidence for is
that they were not they were not told
contemporaneously I don't think it
really provides any evidence that
they're that they're fully untrue it
just provides evidence that people told
these stories way after the fact and
they effed up all the details which is
so common this is what humans do you're
not got a story that's passed down not
written anywhere and is told for 750
years is going to be wrong and of course
it's generally and and eventually then
especially when they start getting told
with a purpose exactly regale their
family member is if I'm gonna tell you
story about you know the history of my
grandfather's grandfather's grandfather
I'm probably going to add elements to
that story that are common and familiar
to myself so you know camels were used
as pack animals much later those are
going to make their way into the story
for that very reason because we are
selfish creatures and we're very
self-centered and when we talk to people
we're going to introduce elements from
our own lives and I've got another movie
reference for you
wasn't that at the point of the movie
300 where they told this crazy story
that was based in truth but there really
weren't giant monsters and two-headed
beast and yeah that was the story wasn't
that I think there was a plot there was
yes I remember I you know the sequel was
out I saw the bill yeah yeah and there's
no way that if camels showed up in about
900 BC was I think what they said as
opposed to 1500 to 2,000 and the and the
biblical stories where there are camels
like no one in 900 even like like you
say I don't there's probably no even
mischief there they're not saying things
that are out there like right I don't
know whether I put if they're here now I
presume they were like how the [ __ ] did
you get across the desert he must have
had a camel I mean that's you know
saying that no believer no literal
believer is gonna look at the science
and then go
all right anybody who's who believes in
a literal translation of the Bible
anybody who's a fundamentalist Christian
is already ignoring so much scientific
evidence this is just one more place to
look than that could this is not going
to convince Ken Ham that Bill Nye was
right but you know but that said you
know as the the you know is religion you
know you know Pat Robertson this week
was critical of Ken Ham you've read
multiple times that if you believe in a
literal translation of the Bible you're
just not doing it right because there's
no way the earth is 6,000 years old yes
I mean if Pat Robertson thinks you're
extreme so that showed me to some extent
that that the religions future which
will still be vibrant and strong it will
just be not it will be taking this as
words to live by but not words but not
the historical fact I agree I mean even
religion is subject to evolution and I
think that what we're going to see in
future generations is a much looser
adaptation of these books and a much
more educated approach to religion you
know we're gonna look to the theologians
and we're gonna say okay these are
stories these are parables like you said
they're words to live by
there's it happened in a procerus I just
doesn't apply to most of these stories
don't worry they'll still hate gays yeah
hallelujah
don't praise Jesus